alors concernant le la politique de la
BCE de remonter des taux d'intérêt alors
les effets que ça va avoir évidemment et
ça va avoir un effet probablement de
d'éclatement d'une bulle immobilière
parce que je pense qu'il y a eu
l'Immobilière avec les niveaux
anormalement bas qu'on a eu sur les prix
d'actifs et ça c'est danger du point de
vue des banques crise immobilière c'est
vraiment danger parce que ça veut dire
que c'est la valeur du collatéral qui va
s'effondrer et donc la capacité à
rembourser les prêts et en plus la
valeur de la garantie ça on connaît bien
on connaît bien le mécanisme la valeur
de la baisse de la valeur des actifs
donc voilà donc et on peut quel bon
niveau de taux d'intérêt sincèrement je
suis incapable de le dire mais surtout
on peut s'interroger sur est-ce que
c'est le bon outil pour
lutter contre l'inflation telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui même la BCE
aujourd'hui a souligner que la boucle
c'est pas une boucle pris de salaire
c'est une boucle prix profit pour
l'instant essentiellement qui alimente
la dynamique plus comme vous l'avez
souligné des facteurs des composants la
plus volatils de l'inflation qui pour
l'instant d'ailleurs ont plutôt baissé
et notamment avec le départ la crise
énergétique et l'échelle de valeur
perturbées suite à la crise covid etc
donc on peut se poser la question est-ce
que ce sont les bons moyens et
d'ailleurs même certains banquiers
centraux on fait des annonces là-dessus
notamment l'inflation d'origine
climatique vous l'avez évoqué Isabelle
Schnabel membre du directoire a fait un
superbe discours sur les trois types
d'inflation faut-il fashion green
flexion et bon bref et donc une
inflation qui est liée à la transition
énergétique et ça c'est pas une hausse
des taux d'intérêt indifférencier qui y
répond ça peut être par contre des taux
très favorables si on finance la
transition écologique externe voilà